good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1299 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 1299 is to be contained
in an 8 by 10 by 4 meter concrete cell
it is to be kept disconnected from all
sources of water regardless of its
current state the door to its
containment chamber is to remain locked
at all times unless procedure f30 is
being enacted all level 2 and above
staff members on-site are to carry keys
to SCP 1299 s containment cell once a
month 1 d class is to enact procedure F
30 in case of a containment breach
essential personnel are advised to move
as far away as possible from the
containment area and any available
female d-class are to be escorted
towards the breach site by security
description SCP 1299 is a white
porcelain / steel free-standing bathtub
manufactured in by the corporation it
was discovered when the occupants of a
house on 75 Street and Ohio experienced
an unusually high rate of apparent
suicides and murders by a drowning a
news story on the anomaly brought the
house to the foundation's attention the
foundation quickly suppressed all
information regarding the crimes and
secured the house in question no
anomalies were observed until one agent
turned on the handle to SCP 1299 which
activated despite being disconnected
from the houses water supply resulting
in the agent's death
the foundation quickly secured the
bathtub and moved it to its current
containment when a living human touches
one or two of the handles on SCP 1299
the tub will begin filling with water
once the tub is filled an invisible
force designated SCP 1299 one will pull
the subject into a CP 1299 and force the
subject under water an imprint of a pair
of hands will appear around the subjects
neck while they attempt to escape
barring outside intervention the subject
will invariably drown at which point the
water will begin to drain via unknown
means until the containment chamber is
completely dry the corpse may then be
retrieved safely if by the 26th night of
each month no living body has touched
the handles or as in the room SCP 1299
one will manifest and leave SCP 1299
leaving a trail of wet humanoid
footprints it will seek out the nearest
living human body which it will drag
back to SCP 1299 and begin to drown as
normal if the process is interrupted and
the subject pulled away from SCP 1299 1
these subjects personality will undergo
a complete resequencing for additional
information see addendum 1299 0-1 SCP
1299 1 is intangible and impossible to
damage by any means yet tested and does
not appear on thermal imaging or x-ray
scanning for additional information see
testing log 12 99 a testing law 12:19 9
a
subject 1 d-class personnel d9 85 with
background and plumbing conditions D 9 8
5 instructed to attach SCP 1299 2 newly
constructed water pipe result SCP 1299
began filling autonomously and SCP 1299
one immediately dragged D 9 8 5 into SCP
1299 to drown him immediately after D 9
8 5 s death footprints characteristic of
scp-1234 betrayal to wards and through
the locked door to the containment
chamber SCP 12 1991 proceeded to grab
one of the two guards stationed outside
and pull him through the still locked
door into a CP 1299 site personnel were
alerted of a containment bridge SCP 12
1991 continued to seize and drown
personnel until it successfully killed a
female d-class at which point SCP 1299
deactivated the pipe was removed without
further incident note testing of SCP 12
99 to be halted until further notice
procedure F 30 to continue as scheduled
recommend female subjects to avoid a
second containment breach doctor
addendum 1299 Oh one 2008 doctor the
researcher who was at the time
overseeing a CP 1299 attempted to alter
the conditions of procedure f30
without proper authorization d 11:30 was
introduced to the testing environment
and instructed to enter the bathtub /
regulation but when SCP 1299 one
appeared doctor breached containment and
attempted to pull the subject out of
scp-1234
[Music]
subject was removed from SCP 1299 and
the instance of scp-1234 examination and
interview d 11:30 refer to himself as a
female who had been killed by drowning
years ago in New York her boyfriend had
been convicted of her murder though the
evidence was purely circumstantial after
gathering all available information the
subject was terminated for full logs see
interview $12.99 a 1 day later a second
d-class was used in procedure of 30 to
prevent a containment breach
experiments are currently ongoing to
determine the cause and results of this
secondary effect
testing log $12.99 be subject to d-class
personnel be 701 and 803 conditions D
701 instructed to touch handle then D
803 and 701 both instructed to lie down
in a CP 1299 result after 30 seconds SCP
12 1991 appeared and attacked both
subjects simultaneously three guards
pulled the subjects from the water both
subjects claimed to be a 25 year old
female whose husband killed her by
drowning her in a bathtub
each subject expressed extreme distress
at others assertions both were able to
recall intimate details of life D 803
was terminated and the 701 was used as a
subject for procedure F 30 subject 1
d-class personnel D 942 conditions D 942
sent in wired to recording net attached
to EEG in order to perform procedure F
30 security instructed to pull subject
out after 5 seconds result at one point
two five seconds after a CP 1299 ones
attack D 942 briefly displayed brainwave
patterns consistent with the onset of a
grand mal epileptic seizure before
almost immediately returning to that of
an excited state typical of a person
being drowned as CP 1299 one called
recording net off subject after two
seconds
subject 1 d-class personnel d-10 74
conditions the 1074 sent in to perform
procedure F 30 security instructed to
remove sample of water from SCP 1299
result have 30 enacted successfully
water sample retrieved sample showed no
anomalous properties mineral
concentrations and pH were found to be
typical of municipal tap water from New
York subject 1 d-class personnel D 873
conditions SCP 1299 filled using hose
attached to external water source d 873
positioned in containment chamber in
case of scp-1225 being completely filled
SCP 1299 1 attacked d 873 initiating
procedure F 30 subject 1 d-class
personnel D 1132 conditions SCP 1299
filled with bleach supplied by hose d
1132 positioned in containment chamber
in case of SCP 12,000 result no
activation of scp-1225
d 894 conditions d 894 brought in to
enact procedure F 30 as scheduled result
upon seeing a CP 1299 D 894 retreated to
the far corner of the room and stayed
there screaming until escorted out of
the room by security personnel C
interview 1299 B
[Music]
this is interview $12.99 a playing log
now interviewed subject 11:30
interviewer forward interview with
breached containment during procedure
[Music]
[Music]
11:30 gets up and attempts to grab
doctor but is shot twice by agent
closing statement subjects description
was found to match the exact date and
suspected time of the drowning by her
boyfriend and this is interviewed $12.99
be playing log now for word interview
with subject D 894 after subject
displayed familiarity with and fear of
SCP 12
I hear screaming coming from upstairs so
I rush into the bathroom and see her
thrashing in the top by the time I get
to her she's dead so turns out the
neighbor also heard the screams and
called the cops well guess who gets the
murder charges which means you stopped
it so you can tell the world the truth
you can give me off this whole sentence
thank you for your cooperation
DEA 94 your case will be attended to
thank you doctor thank you so much thank
you thank you closing statement subject
given be class on ethics and moved back
to holding facilities
I think that about does it for today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
hello this is Lumi welcome was kind
enough to allow me to say hello to you
all and tell you that if you would like
to hear me read more stories or which
may play some video games you can follow
link in the description to my channel
and check out my content see you later
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert James
Sabah Kareem ela shmuly Justin day
Thomas Morin Curie kuma and jayvo Jack
crystal spice goddess of Donuts my
archive curator Nick Joseph Lewis ooh
agent vamp King modding the wanderer and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the volga thank you
you